[Music]
Harry Styles his new single sign at the
Times has everyone buzzing including
some One Direction band mates now
Horan's we did a love at age on Friday
shortly after Harry premiered his first
solo single Wow Liam Payne said a proud
of you age glad you're getting to do
your own thing
you're pretty good down here peculiar
really good the song shot to number one
on iTunes shortly after its release and
music critics across the board say the
surprising 60s sounding song is a smash
Perry chatted with BBC one in London
revealing his mom is also a fan of the
tune and what his family thinks of his
upcoming album have you played it to
your mom I have and what did your mom
think my mum liked it yeah which was
handy yeah I played the album to the to
the first time and there's one song on
the album where is like a bit with like
a vocal effect on it and my stepdad goes
where did you get the duck from but how
did you get into that I'm like yeah that
was me thanks thanks
[Music]